wer als kind und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video in dem ich heute meine
fünf schlimmsten momenten vorstellen zu
dem zweck sind wir vor meiner alten
schule
ich sag lieber nicht weiter ins weite
des jahres fort und will sie auf jeden
fall wir legen gleich verloren
[Musik]
moment mal einen verdammten neunten
klasse hatte ich vor allem eine kräftige
ein ziemlich gute stube thomas derweil
einem kleinen test im wirtschaftsrecht
waldhof hatte keinen plan überhaupt
keine andere beschreiben leute der
dummkopf der wartenberger mich gefallen
ich habe einfach in meiner schullaufbahn
bis dahin noch nie gespielt hab sogar
bis heute glaube ich echt noch nie
geschmeckt nicht in der unheimlichen der
schule aber dieses eine mal wo ich
niemandem geholfen hat ja gar nicht mein
eigenes team geholfen stimmungslage weiß
nachdem er mich gefragt hat der lehrer
sieht mich und ich krieg' ich fucking
weg solchen helfen wollte und der andere
partei zu stimmen
der einzige mensch den ich bin heute
moment nummer zwei der schlimmsten
momente hat sich direkt nach dem spiel
das nicht nur in der schule versetzt
aber es steht immer noch in england für
schule und war in der schule wird an die
ganze zeit sagt er die muss das machen
und du musst nach dem motiv machen
keine widerrede macht einfach und halt
die schnauze und nach der schule
eigenständiger menschlich habe besonders
jungen abitur gemacht junge daher
jungholz findigkeit bereich ein großes
problem das macht die schule so kein
platzmangel versorgen wenn ich so
zurückdenke hätte ich damals nicht ganz
gerne mehr orientierung gehabt aber
wasser ein kann die zeiten sich
verändert
diese zeiten anderem deswegen gibt es
mittlerweile auch schon apps mit dem man
die orientieren kann und in
zusammenarbeit mit einer dieser apps der
känguru ist dieses video entstanden
deswegen stehe ich jetzt die abdrücke
nicht vor
sie hat die etwa komplett clean gehalten
dass sie genauso liebe euch wenn ihr
gestartet wenn man die app öffnet sagte
er sein wo man es hier oben
es kann man hier lernt check starten und
immer darauf geben da kann man jetzt
hier ist für drei bereiche auswählen die
meist sind das hier einfach mal so als
würde ich selbst für ausgemachte
passiert nicht büro handel interessiert
mich was sind das für nicht besonders
bei büro handel verkaufen und kaufen 134
feier plätze was er bisher auch menschen
helfen
nach ecken selbst treffen verschwindet
nicht schlecht verändert wie 50 weitete
alles klar was ich noch etwas für ihre
kunden beraten landet im bereich
einfacher unterbreite auf die öl da
kommen zwei weitere bereiche aussteller
wie lange das noch fertig sind dann
kriegt man hier ausbildung in den nähe
vorgeschlagen man kann einfach direkt
hier über die suche die stille sucht
also alles lang mit der wirklichkeit
design hier bei diesem spiel kann man
noch sein profil erstellen seine
bewerbungsmappe und sich dann direkt aus
der er auf ausbildungsstellen bewerben
die ganze geschichte ist kopflos und ich
finde das ziemlich nach sache wenn man
sich direkt aus der app ob bewerben kann
also nicht nur eine spielerei oder gar
nicht suchen wenn man kann sich
tatsächlich bewerben und persönlich bin
jemand der riesen probleme hat damit
bewerbung zu schreiben ich passe das
einfach das ist unglaublich geil dass er
das nicht so leicht machen kann hätte
ich gesagt kostenlos den link dazu falls
ihr das auto bin möchtet ist in der
beschreibung
[Musik]
potreck city war schon der dritte
die dritte moment hat mit dem weg zur
schule zu tun oder mit diesen dingen
werden ich musste immer mit dem
fahrradfahrer kam ich nicht gefahren was
nicht scheitern muss man ruhig und egal
welche strecke und haben nicht länger
gedauert hat dem muss ich ja mit fahrrad
fahren und wirklich waren morgens
aufgestanden ist
man geht vor die tür und es regnet schon
seine taschen immer alle will ihr müsst
im regen zu fahren
mit schulen halte ich glaube zweite
stunde beginnt und alle möglichen leute
lachen weil auf der bitte das video
darüber machen können hörer wieder ins
auto wären sie in unsere hände sind
heute alle minus fünf grad in köln
und ich wusste grips okay leute nummer
vier ist eine sache wahrscheinlich auch
waffen nachvollziehen können und zwar
ohne gekündigte abfragen und es diese
verdammte angst vor jeder stunde am
anfang wenn man auf dem platz und
schenkt bitten sich bitte nicht ich
hätte mich und wenn irgendeiner
aufgerufen für den gleiche arbeit danke
ein weiterer tag überlebt das ist
richtig scheiße eigentlich warum gibst
du was cool ist schon anstrengend genug
beginnen wir jetzt selber irgendwie
würde man russisch roulette spirit of
thrones schullehrer verkauft damit nimmt
france direktor so davon verschaffen
[Musik]
zu guter letzt leute punkt nummer fünf
für mich eine person die morgens das
bett kommt das schlimmste und zwar jeden
morgen früh aufsteht es hat mich
wirklich aufgeregt wie aufscheint ich
morgens in der dusche total am ende
dachte mir
sie lernen durch die schaltung mit
waffen wie lange war ich diese scheitel
und mitmachen
warum mache ich das wort mit aber leute
am ende hat man es doch nicht gestanden
deswegen sage ich auch alle von euch die
jetzt keinen der schule sind ich kann
allen partien ist es sehr anstrengend es
ist eher nervig und jeden morgen zeigt
geht manchem ich für aber ich fange
immer mehr durch warum eigentlich
eigentlich kein bock aber ihr haltet
durch
er macht eine gute ausbildung sagt ihr
könnt es schaffen wenn ich jetzt
zurückdenke denken auch okay wir haben
das durchgestanden habe man stets immer
irgendwie durch von ihr wanderfreunde
und leute um sich rum hat diese auch
machen diesen sinne dass man meine 55
uhr mit der bahn bis zum nächsten mal
die sagt link zur abschreibung macht gut
an
beim kunstvollen